on va revenir avec notre invité sur ce
premier procès pour crime de guerre qui
s'ouvre en ukraine celui d'un soldat
russe de 21 ans accusé d'avoir abattu un
civils non-armés ça s'est passé près de
soumis fin février au début de
l'invasion russe nous sommes avec
william julier avocat au barreau de
paris spécialisé en droit pénal
international william julie et bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur
france 24 ce soldat de 21 ans est accusé
d'avoir abattu je le disais un civil de
62 ans non-armés fin février dans la
région de soumis c'est une violation du
droit de la guerre on pourra à
l'occasion de ce procès entendre la
version de ce soldat qu'est ce qu'il
risque
et risque une peine de prison importante
son avocat va le défendre on comprend
que il aurait avoué les faits et reconnu
avoir tiré sur ce civil j'ai pu lire
mais je n'ai pas eu accès au dossier
donc évidemment avec prudence cette
remarque qu'il avait dit qu'on lui avait
intimé l'ordre de tirer et puis le
procureur qui va mener des poursuites
pendant ce procès va requérir une peine
on ne sait pas encore laquelle et puis
le tribunal prendra une décision qui
sera susceptible de voies de recours et
on verra à ce moment là en fonction de
la décision ce que ce que la personne
éventuellement condamner décidera de
faire justement jugé de simples
militaire avant même de poursuivre des
hauts gradés pour de tels faits c'est
rare sur le plan international
alors écoutez c'est rare et c'est pas
rare parce que c'est pas une justice
internationale qui va être rendu là
c'était une justice nationale c'est ça
qui est non pas extraordinaire parce
qu'il ya des précédents
la justice nationale
des pays dans lesquels des crimes sont
commis et notamment des crimes de guerre
peut se saisir de poursuites ça a été le
cas avec des crimes de guerre au congo
assez récemment d'ailleurs il ya eu un
procès en avril 2022 ça a été le cas
avec le kosovo
ça a été également le cas en rapport
avec d'autres d'autres pays ce qui est
particulier ici c'est que les poursuites
sont menées pendant que le conflit est
encore en déroulement conflit d'ailleurs
armée internationale union
internationale mais la justice d'un pays
se saisit aujourd'hui d'un crime de
guerre
potentiellement commis sur son sol alors
que le conflit armé est encore en
déroulement et là il ya quelque chose
d'exceptionnel parce que je ne crois pas
que ça se soit déjà produit c'est cette
concomitance qui est particulière et
pour répondre à votre question le fait
que ce soit des exécutants si on peut
l'appeler comme ça en tout cas dans les
corps armés et bien qu'il soit poursuivi
pour la commission de crimes de guerre
c'est quelque chose qui est normal au
plan de la justice qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs internationales ou nationales
la mise en cause de responsabilité on va
dire plus hot de donneurs d'ordres et
notamment de personnes qui peuvent ne
pas être simplement des militaires mais
aussi des responsables politiques là
c'est un autre sujet qui concerne
peut-être plus la justice pénale
internationale comme vous l'avez pointer
et pour des raisons liées mais on pourra
en parler peut-être dans une seconde aux
problématiques d'immunité alors ce
procès vous l'avez évoqué il a lieu
alors que le conflit est toujours en
cours est ce que justement ça n'arrive
pas un petit peu trop tôt est ce qu'il
pourra dans ces conditions ce procès est
reconduit correctement
alors
c'est une discussion en effet qui mérite
d'être tenu moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent que la justice peut se tenir
qu'un conflit soit en cours ou pas en
cours l'institution judiciaire
est indépendante elle doit être capable
de mener des procès
en fonction des règles de droit est
d'aboutir à des décisions de
condamnations d'ailleurs ou de non
condamnation non pas sur la base de
l'opinion publique ou de l'émotion mais
sur la base du droit et il n'a échappé à
personne que ce procès
est hautement médiatisé il participe
d'ailleurs sans doute aussi du travail
de communication des ukrainiens qui
voit là en oeuvre par tous les moyens
possibles on entend des dents dans votre
rappel des faits précédents que le
président ukrainien était intervenu en
duplex au festival de cannes hier donc
les caméras peut-être pas du monde
entier mais beaucoup de pays du monde
sont fixés aujourd'hui sur ce procès et
je pense que la justice ukrainienne va
faire tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
que ce procès soit conduite façon
exemplaire donc moi je pense qu'un
procès peut se tenir même lorsqu'un
conflit est encore en cours de
déroulement c'est un procès qui va se
tenir comme il s'en tenait avant et
comme il faut espérer il s'en tiendra
après la force de ce procès c'est la
résilience justement d'institutions
judiciaires ukrainienne
l'armée est résiliente mais les
institutions le sont aussi et je crois
que c'est un signe très fort symbolique
mais pas seulement et bien de ce que le
pays tient que ces institutions et il
faut le préciser civile dans les
exemples que j'ai pris tout à l'heure
notamment au congo
eh bien ce sont des tribunaux militaires
qui ont jugé la saga état de guerre
commis c'est une justice c'est une
justice civile ça va être un test
justement c'est à votre honneur
ça va être un test pour cette justice
eut gelé nien je pense que
oui enfin
c'est même pas un test je crois que la
justice ukrainienne étaient une justice
peut-être pas parfaite mais aucune ne
l'est
démocratique avant le conflit et je
crois qu'elle va continuer à être comme
cela lorsqu'on a vu le procureur dès les
premières jouent deux jours du conflit
pardon dès les premiers jours du conflit
être sur le terrain enquêtaient
construire des dossiers eh bien ça à
prouver que la société civile tenez bon
et que toutes les institutions n'avait
pas disparu la justice pénale
internationale est une justice dans son
principe déjà de complémentarité de
subsidiarité le principe c'est que les
institutions pénales internationales
entre en jeu lorsque dans les pays il
n'ya plus possibilité que la justice
passe mais le but c'est que les pays
puissent défendre et bien leurs
institutions et faire passer la justice
sans avoir besoin de l'aide extérieure a
peut-être ce petit delta près que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui est celui
des problématiques d'immunité lorsqu'on
vient à vouloir mettre en cause des
responsabilités notamment des chefs
d'état et ça c'est une autre question
pour ce qui est de la mise en cause des
responsabilités de ceux qui ne sont pas
protégés par ces immunités et bien je
suis de ceux qui pensent que c'est très
bien que cette justice puisse être
rendue dans les pays en question avec
l'aide au niveau du rassemblement des
preuves et bien deux procureurs
étrangers de procureur de la cour pénale
internationale
et on sait qu'il ya une coopération très
intenses depuis maintenant de longues
semaines entre les services d' enquête
procureur ou police étrangers ou de la
cpi et les services secrets bien merci
beaucoup william juliet d'avoir été
notre invité sur france 24